when welcome to this show I'm back yeah
after four weeks I hope you're all right
and enjoyed the time without my shows
Monday evenings but I'm back and I'm
going to play a couple of blitz games
here on the ICC let's get going I'm
going to request a five-minute game yeah
who's in the chat we've got some regular
some gasps oops
what's that flying law office again yeah
so it meat grinder had his birthday yeah
happy birthday it's just two or three
days late yeah even if you request the
Latvian gambit I still don't think I
want to play it okay I've got the game
request out but I'm not yet paired some
good players on good question here by
Hatillo who will win the World Cup
hmm yeah well win the World Cup who's a
Aronian mdl ding and and Wesley so hmm
MV oh yeah I have to say something I
mean we have to see that this is of
course also about tournament chess but
it's also about rapid and blitz skill
and of course the other players are not
bad there either but I think MDL is my
favorite there but it's a close call
yeah okay the request is out but I don't
you can start it I know I get a pairing
FM Neyman okay is that this is a man
well nine men a threesome he has written
a book
at least one book together with treasure
master effect invisible chess moves
that's a pretty cool book okay so we get
a scotch four nights opening that I
recently checked a little bit yeah
Bioshock right size also on okay got all
the regulars in the chat not all of them
but a lot yeah so what is White's idea
I'm developing my pieces and and I've
got a very healthy pawn structure I just
have to pawn islands a to see pawn and
after each pawn black has three islands
that doesn't really mean all that much
but it is a factor interesting requests
were made grind ever could try if I
could try put a s key night off hmm hmm
I don't know this is not exactly wait
route before sometimes an issue let's do
this
point is keen-eyed off I mean I can try
the night off
it's not exactly what I know well but I
can I can try okay so do I put this here
for c4 I'll try a question about
Victoria cow if you want to study pawn
structures for example the carts but
it's the way to go only by buying a book
is there any other way
yeah I think it's not a bad idea to get
a good book on strategy I mean there's
probably also software but not problem
there is software on strategy but there
are also some really really decent books
on those subjects in terms of porn
structures I am often recommend the the
book what is it called actually by
Marcelo Flores Rios or something
Marcelo by Flores Rios pawn structures
something I don't remember the exact
title I think it's a good one I think
it's his chest structures ok ah good
question how was my vacation yeah
excellent I absolutely enjoyed it this
wasn't a good move as a sea route before
yeah
it wasn't all that great
yeah chess structures a grandmaster
guide and that wasn't good yeah a four
is hanging and Queen c7 does not help
no I was a very stupid mistake I
actually already was in pretty decent
shape he he gave me the C form both
basically for free yeah I just recognize
that he cannot actually take on a 4
because of Bishop b5 which is of course
pure coincidence but he still can be
happy about damaging my structure there
yeah there are programs for the Mac for
chess but well you don't get chess base
which is kind of what you need there are
other other programs but I don't I mean
I tried something on Mac I don't know
what was the name of the program it no
it just does not really do the trick if
you want to do something professional
you just need chess base okay so what is
this yeah isn't he kind of misplacing
stuff I don't think chess base works
well in wine yeah there's also chess
base online
yeah well anyway it's a it's a tricky
subject yeah now d5 is hanging and I'm
threatening Bishop a6
and he attacks my rook simply mmm-hmm
and let's just do this
cannot be Badham and it's also this
problem called sit SC ID yeah I'm not an
expert I mean for databases I use chess
base since version 1 1988 yeah so yeah
it's a bit of a problem here what is he
doing him yeah now I can I can just take
with the rook which is better for white
but maybe I can also move the bishop him
and keep this attacked Bishop f5 is such
a move and I know maybe I've got
something better even but let this work
yeah rooks see one that's 92 so no
option but I can take him and now
where'd you put the bishop probably him
he's also having some issues here with
the time so on 26 seconds which is not
not so great really yeah maybe maybe I
can shock him with this move if he takes
Queen takes Queen h8 the rook is hanging
okay then 94 is actually decent yeah
attacking well that's almost time
morning
there's no mate that's kind of a shame I
can check and play rook c8 check here
King h2 and then I take this check
should actually work and rook c8
yeah it could be one chick I can also
take me besides winning on time Jack
yeah yeah the knight on c3 is hanging
with a check black for fits on time Jeff
there was tricky I will look some stuff
but I know maybe it was okay just by
coincidence getting new game requests
out it's a question about the black
majima gambit oh my god now it's pretty
pretty bad opening and there are many
ways to get a good position against this
really in many ways this is the thing if
there was like one complicated where you
had there are many ways it's just not a
really good Queen d6 check yeah
game started yeah you're right c3 is
also hanging with a check but I didn't
see that one okay
so brick top is the opponent aha Steiner
Lima says he also went to Slovenia this
summer yeah where did you go
a couple of good places to visit stayed
in the air in the Alps so where exactly
did you stay
I just realized that there's a slight
issue here Queen B 7s 95 so I have to go
here
Yokogawa is really really a nice place
I've been down on visiting it um but it
was probably not the best time of the
year to visit it was still pretty nice
I've been been going down like in May
middle of May
yeah I cannot take it off this name
night takes and then d5 is hanging there
should be seven last night a five which
is pretty pretty weird
I would but strong maybe Bishop e6 I
should have played this is really weird
yeah my idea was to take with the porn
simply and I could take with the night
obviously it's the better choice from a
structural point of view but I don't
know they never get developed yeah I'm
at least the taking of the bishop and I
mean it doesn't have that many red
squares I mean white has compensation
here obviously but we'll see how bad it
is
he's going to play eform this the thing
I have to go back then to f6
yeah blade is also nice place to stay
what to c7 but probably he has better
yeah the 2002 chess olympiad wasn't
billion in blade hmm yeah blade had many
[Music]
many chess events actually the 2002
chess olympiad and the candidates
tournament in I think in 64 59 50s or so
yeah Fischer played down some games with
tall and so on yeah okay anyway I'm in
really really in a critical state here
maybe maybe I should actually castlelong
here
a blade is probably the one place in
Slovenia that has that is touristical e
most mostly covered okay I think I'm
doing this I have an eidm I wanted to
prevent a4 a5 of course
so yeah yeah tempo and Knight is 6 I
don't think he wants to trade
then 96 and potentially g5
yeah I'm a bit worried about c6
definitely but white is also I mean d4
could be a very nice square bishop aged
through this g4 okay so going to cover
c6 and then g4 is also on the cards yeah
he probably wants to go 24 time warning
which I tried to prevent and introduced
95 9 f3 here it is fairly chaotic but
the position I think objectively should
be probably good for black but it is
chaotic Wow
opening up the edge file
Queeny seven where do I go
King bee six probably check this fairly
safe and okay would be seven let's get
the foul
he can check this unfortunately that was
a stupid free move well okay it was
quick at least check checkmate
yeah there was stuff probably not a
really good not a good position
somewhere that was tough
okay anyway let's get a new game
requested this line leads to crazy
positions anyway but what do you do you
want to get something going with black
you have to gain started risk a little
bit okay killed yarn see going for me
says he's a super ambitious player so I
will probably not play a normal line
this is actually kind of kind of funky
but okay so f6
it's that good I don't know hmm I can go
here and force him to take
the Hmong God wrote no I don't I don't
think that I've visited dad okay son I
have 7:45 is probably his idea
it's that's I mean I want to go Bishop
h6 the fee analysis would be nice
no so g5 is on his agenda so I go for
Bishop t4 then if he goes g5 ff4 be to
his hanging I just recognized that
didn't see it before
yeah
yet do I have compensation here well not
enough but also not 0 this is 6 as a
good square in the night somewhat stupid
man God wrote I mean I know the this I
think I know what you mean I just know
it under under a different name maybe
I've tried to go onto this village I
cannot pronounce that yeah I don't I
don't really know how to write it either
I just tracked it write it in the chat
yeah this was one of the highest player
points in Slovenia and you can go there
by car it's crazy high the first game
Aronian even show care that was a very
good one see for display there by um by
Levon
do hear you create the kind of annoying
for black but as each power passes
another Road yeah okay I only know that
one still not easy for black to do much
he will do something however yeah is
that good hmm cannot cannot take still
[Music]
it's something that I should have
prevented by just going back then I have
enough compensation here this is
actually doubtful never have enough you
can take the pawn on e6 but this is
extremely risky of course he does it and
he never plays any sort of modest move
it's always the sharpest and oftentimes
it just doesn't work but it has to be
always the most ambitious move yeah now
I don't know maybe it's okay for him but
I think I have some pretty decent
compensation rookie six then would be
seven it's definitely enough he can
barely move then but maybe he's got some
other idea no Queen a one cheek
hmm and that's an interesting move check
95 or something something crazy is the
idea
I mean King age 6
hmm King age six g5 I don't know if that
is even good young Knight takes pawn
takes Queen takes chick yeah this this
was it was kind of the debt that I
suspected that so I take this check twin
g2 is got a boatload of checks I have to
check it anyway check check
maybe he just takes on e5 and place this
position now my king position is really
really shaky
check-check
[Music]
I don't think he will draw not not this
guy it's also not necessary probably
maybe due to the time also yeah so this
one look f2 asleep is the point so I can
check King h8
time warning yeah I don't I don't have a
really clear continuation here that's
really not the case maybe just go back
or something I don't know I don't know I
have to make a move my check is probably
good yeah hey I can check cheeky one
crew keV - yeah it's a very
uncomfortable position
[Music]
nice could this check as well friggin
hell no white resigned I don't know I
was kind of unnecessary I guess but it
was definitely tricky let's go for a new
game I don't know I never believed what
he plays never I mean because it's
always the most ambitious game and that
started that shouldn't work anyway so
let's see what happens here maybe it was
okay in this game I don't know so you
got oh okay the three line check yeah
I'm playing this most direct
continuation attacking white center
immediately this normally wins the pawn
back but the development is sometimes a
bit questionable Knight f3 is a good
move now
let's see what happens here I've have
really forgotten some of those lines
it's been quite a while since I checked
a German you could flecked him how I was
down on time how can I flag him plus I
was getting checkmated or loss the Queen
funny funny intermediate move okay so is
this what is this said so bad the
diagonal looks scary
definitely
yeah let's develop hmm there where's he
going what's the point
Queen here this Bishop f ed so and then
he will probably take and play 25
[Music]
could have six though
trying to play deform
let's see what he does okay
age five didn't react to my idea so if
he takes it
I was thinking pancakes but I might
think we denied actually that could be
an idea I don't think my position it can
be terrible because all the pieces are
doing something so it would be
surprising to see that I'm in deep
trouble
at least surprising to me Jim looks kind
of normal for white to take on d4 if he
takes his six I take c3 that that's
leading absolutely nowhere okay so he
does he does go back so what is the deal
and I can ignite a7 my 97 looks and I
could be a decision
I can I can detect the Queen a little
bit I don't know I'm not quite sure what
to do yeah it's got King Queenie form
which is a simple simple way to blame
how are the pre stupid move yeah rook d5
has suggested in the chat would have
been interesting yeah I I thought about
it but yeah somehow I felt Bishop d6 is
an idea and this is of course complete
nonsense
and still I still think this should be
playable all the sudden is taking lots
of time so here is the e6 pawn f5
I don't know if this is a good move yeah
I can take this but it looks extremely
shaky be one Queen a3 yeah probably I
cannot do it
so
and then probably queen-to-be 7's coming
pretty awkward okay taking the bishop at
least I would be quite okay with giving
up an exchange like b3 takes takes Queen
a6
that could be playable kd3 doesn't help
pretty awkward just taking the pawn down
[Music]
check say anyway my morning to activate
this stuff here 93 rice playing this
quite well no I wanted to
that was a mouse slip but maybe this
isn't so so terrible I didn't want to do
this it and it is a sailfin ping come on
now you're playing everything perfectly
or what five-second drawford okay and
nowhere was that was maybe actually here
I wanted to play d3 and then I don't
know I don't know maybe this is not so
terrible
okay the points are very dangerous
anyway
I don't think you can see I can with the
dark squared bishop s-- after III and
taking on b5
I don't know at the end I might win on
time I don't know but I'm really really
really bad in bad shape then okay so
I've got a game request I would I think
yeah I mean you know I'm not sure
they're here if I can I mean I can try
to flag him I see what the six seconds
is the thing I mean I didn't really see
a move to continue
game started okay so our penguin is the
next opponent yeah you have to bear with
me playing that exchange variation but
I'm doing quite okay with this so what
is he going to do now to be six probably
Knight to d5 this is what they often do
but I'm quite happy yeah I think white
is in good shape not like I'm much
better or so but it's a good open
position so what did what did you put it
on e5 yes then maybe Queen f3 next okay
so he rather wants to weaken as
pollution okay
there is no tactic yeah but I can't go
here trying to grab the bishop which is
prevented yeah I think white has really
good active pieces so it's kind of okay
to play
you never play of sixes as some been
Feingold's rule right yeah he might be
okay with this f6 business 93 Bishop f6
I can just trade stuff but doesn't
doesn't really make such a bad
impression now if he gets to have 7 that
might be okay aha
that looks a little bit scared
I know to f5 I seem but I can go h6
right
especially for really a problem don't
know
hmmm interesting so this is an annoying
pawn but he has he has some also gained
a bit of space them
like pawns e4 Knight and Bishop g4 tough
am not so easy he would probably take my
ideas to put this on c3 but I don't know
Bishop g4 24 I don't know it's probably
that is okay for him should be okay he
wins lots of time rookie aid and so on
now I was hoping that I can do stuff
against the king but he's just too
active yeah all those moves him
hmm that's true hmm that didn't look all
that that didn't go all that well check
I really shouldn't lose against this
person I have a fantastic score against
him but position is not good yeah really
not his King is still an issue it's not
it's not easy to convert I think at
least I don't see it okay now I can get
to the seventh
[Music]
hmm let's take this rather yeah but you
cannot go to the five I mean I mean you
can but I get to see to attacking age
seven hmm I might I may be getting
somewhere
okay so what is idea rookies six I can
also just take it but it looks it looks
somewhat more interesting
yeah I mean if he leaves the back rank
I have woopsie aid i takes this ok can
go into the seventh again attacking the
pawn in the process the abacus got he's
got rook d6
I only saw that now okay so I cannot
take and I don't need to I mean black
black cannot do anything anyway okay so
[Music]
I mean maybe he can go into the second
ring but you seven I can't go here time
warning
hmm I wish a deal of some time to figure
this out
Luke a8 Bishop e6 is made if I get Jason
really check
ah okay that's the point check
hmmm I wonder can I win this game try
this already a draw okay it was it was
interesting I mean NEVER interesting
maybe I
I mean maybe I had something even tough
tough somewhere I got counterplay okay
so one more game and that's it for the
session
hmm what I guess not only you're
thinking of that yeah you can of course
yeah
he had can play this but he will take
and I wasn't quite sure what I'm doing
next maybe you can play this but my
clock you know gain started out that I'm
winning though so the request was the
pure f ski night off him people don't go
for this
yeah this is this assume this is the
line that is Coppedge line hmm yeah
indeed that looks like a it looks a bit
strange for me hmm
I just realized that my knight might be
in trouble but okay like castles Oh Kim
it could be
okay so I think I'm going for this no
don't think that this can be also bad I
mean I don't think I'm better yeah but I
should have counter play against the C
pawn and it's not so clear what white is
doing this no I have to go here Queen
ninety-five there's going to be five
six Bishop f8 bishop f8 now threatens to
win material now almost almost
really but now I'm winning stuff right
why am I not winning material the Queen
has nowhere to go
couldn't be two days night c4 that was
weird
bling white resins or this one almost we
had this pling before anyway I'm going
for yet another game that was a bit
short I don't think I played this right
down theoretically speaking
I don't know game started yam Fantozzi
okay what is Fantozzi up to check lay
this check again super ambitious people
are not really modest nowadays and they
always want the most ambitious stuff it
might be good it might be good so he
wants to go d5 interesting
hmm this one my my development is not
good
d5 96 I was thinking
yeah padula Russell asks how it is going
and if he connected right at the moment
when the livestream ends is this
probably true we answers the last game
very likely
I'm actually on overtime already yeah
that's a bit weird everything here
the father Galli five yeah I kind of
expected this to happen but I couldn't
really do much about it yeah that is
lashing out with b5
take their first
King takes night X and I takes Queen
takes Queen takes Queen deform and
winning these sections probably not much
oh really
okay I can take g6 what is he going to
do we for hmm I don't know is going for
this activity okay
am I going f5 f5 against efore f5 hmm
continuing to be annoying but definitely
correct as a damn risky pre move did I
do primo
queen adria it's not really ideal why I
came in okay
now that looks extremely annoying to be
honest that looks very annoying
hmm should have taken the friggin draw
this doesn't have much upside check guys
got the e pawn which is pretty dangerous
yeah Jim shake it oh this one I go here
just yeah I think it's probably okay so
I need to get something going then and I
have six is definitely too slow
[Music]
okay so he's not really threatening it
to all that much time warning at least I
don't see it
maybe something crazy queen f2 or
something I have King edge - okay I can
also take yeah
now I should have taken the draw earlier
but simply repeating but you know you
don't want that really hit a blitz game
and now it's really really tricky Jim
maybe it's got some shine based on
taking and the ending is okay of course
he goes for that
a group t7 oh so I've got h5 check ok
the ending is fine it's probably just a
draw check draw a third that was the
result that if we couldn't have have
done earlier yeah black probably should
have played differently that looked
really dangerous with the phone
absolutely dangerous ok guys hope you
enjoyed the show after quite a long
break I'll be back next week for yet
another hour of chess hopefully
explained in some coherent way I hope
you will be back then thanks for
watching bye bye